اود اولا ان اقدم خالص التعازي لاسر
الضحايا انها ماساه عرفت بريكوجين منذ
فتره طويله منذ بدايات تسعينيات القرن
الماضي
[موسيقى]
بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم
موسكو تصف لدعاءات الغربيه بشان تورط
الكرملين في مقتل بريجوجين بانها كذبه
مطلقه ورفضت الكشف عن مستقبل مجموعه فاجنر
بينما رجحت واشنطن تفجير الطائره من
الداخل وقالت لندن الى نهايه سيكون لها
تاثير على استقرار
مظاهرات في الشمال السوري تضامنا مع
احتجاجات السويداء جنوبيه البلاد ويطالب
المحتاجون بتحسين الاوضاع المعيشيه ورحيل
النظام وتحقيق انتقال سياسي في البلاد من
خلال رفع لافتات وترديد الشعارات المناهضه
للرئيس بشار الاسد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يغادر سجن فولتن في ولايه جورجيا بعد
ايقافه لمده 20 دقيقه في سابقه هي الاولى
في تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وذلك
لاخذ بصماته والتقاط صوره جنائيه على
خلفيه اتهامه بسعي لتغيير نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه السابقه وقد اطلق
سراحه بعد دفعه كفاله قدرها 200 الف دولار
امريكي ووصف ترامب ان ما يحدث مهزله وتدخل
في الانتخابات القادمه
وزير العدل الدنماركي يعلنوا ان بلاده
ستحضر حرق المصحف الشريف بعد ان اثارت
حوادث تدنيسه غضبا واسعا في العالم
الاسلامي وقال الوزير خلال مؤتمر صحفي ان
الحكومه الدنماركيه قدمت الى البرلمان
مشروع قانون سيحضر التعامل بطريقه غير
مناسبه مع اشياء تكتسي اهميه دينيه كبيره
لجماعه دينيه
[موسيقى]